it's been nearly five months since
russia invaded ukraine and in addition
to the staggering human losses the
united nations estimates more than
cultural sites in ukraine have been
damaged or destroyed now there's an
effort underway more than 6 000 miles
away to preserve ukraine's digital
cultural legacy john blackstone has the
story from san francisco
from her crowded home office in berkeley
california quinn dombrowski has been
drawn into the war in ukraine her
mission is to help preserve ukrainian
culture by rescuing ukrainian websites
we've been crawling through all the
sites that have been registered in
ukraine to look for cultural heritage
sites dombrowski an academic technology
specialist at stanford university is one
of three co-founders of what they call
sutchow for saving ukrainian cultural
heritage online
i thought now everything lived in the
cloud
why do you have to rescue this well so
this is
it's easy to forget that ultimately the
internet comes down to physical things
servers are physical things that can be
destroyed you know just as much as
statues
servers have to be connected to the
internet via cables they need power they
need cooling
and all of these are just as much at
risk as any other thing in the physical
world their group now has more than a
thousand volunteers around the world
using their own computers to identify
and preserve ukrainian websites that
could be lost forever everything we find
we send to the internet archive to
capture via the wayback machine so the
wayback machine is basically a time
machine for the web mark graham is
director of the way back machine at the
internet archive in san francisco it's
why this organization was created in the
first place was to provide a forever
home
to the material that human beings are
creating about themselves about their
world and trying to share with others
the internet archive is housed in a
former san francisco church the pews are
still there but so are banks and banks
of computer servers recording not just
ukrainian websites but others from
around the world they've been doing this
for 26 years with an understanding of
how vulnerable digital records can be
digital artifacts in many ways are much
more fragile than their analog
equivalent
books for example
generally speaking were printed at mass
so if one library burns down the tragedy
that may be there's other libraries with
digital material it's often not like
that buildings at risk of russian
bombardment in ukraine include museums
libraries and schools
places where in peace time computers are
used every day but in wartime
maybe among the forgotten casualties
things like children's libraries where
they have poems written by the young
patrons and the interesting thing about
those sites is that they're not
digitized versions of physical objects
what's digital is all there is these
were only ever digital photos and
digital um poems and so i'm glad that we
have a copy of those so that if the site
goes down there's there's some way to
preserve it with her eight-year-old son
sam helping dombrowski has made a
special effort to save the creations of
ukraine's children there was one site
that had photos from literally days
before the war when they had an art
project for the children um with the
title of i'm ukrainian and that sounds
proud and it's you know pictures that
someone took on their cell phone of
children painting sunflowers and maps of
ukraine and you know when when the war
is over and it's safe to rebuild we can
we can give that back and the memory
will continue for all that has been lost
in ukraine the digital records being
saved by volunteers far away
promised someday to be one building
block for recovery for cbs saturday
morning john blackstone san francisco
one person making such a big difference
he's gonna make that point so concerned
for her the value of these volunteers
underscoring that servers are the key if
you want to preserve what's online
because we think about the cloud and it
feels infinite but it's not because it's
based on actual servers that take up
space here on earth yeah so it's just
like incredible to think about that it's
you know we think of digital copies as
backups but
and she's committed she's got the hair
she's got the shirt she's got the
glasses the sunflowers that you pointed
out yeah she had the national flower of
ukraine in her house that's right